Kumaran Oh welcome not lesser months
till Camellia veterans corpse academia
or the helpers contraction baton scopes
Academy no lawsuit that's it Sam and red
oak the dark so presently rewards no
bellies if you see horns on the way
numeira Academy instantly security
another Omiya made from the oil
professor a new year so Maywood fur and
a Nobel Committee and fifty sick oak
professor olga Boatner laid a mood or
nobel committee and oak expecting a
threesome rodent welcome to the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences it's time to
announce this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics I am Jordan Hansen
secretary-general of the Academy and
with me on the podium is the chair of
the Nobel Committee for physics
professor unruly and professor olga
bottner a member of the Nobel Committee
I will start by reading the announcement
with a citation in the five languages
Alfred Nobel spoke and we will then hear
presentations from our experts on the
panel after that we hope to have one of
the Nobel laureates available on a phone
line and we look forward to your
questions of course in Swedish or in
English or it's please handle our own
identity it's beaten who's know growl
innovations born last in vulnera this
year's prize is about changes of
identity among some of the most abundant
inhabitants in the universe come Leah vo
scopes Academy in hot pursuit that
Attila Hugo and FM tonneaus mobile
please if you see till Takaaki kajita
of author the mcdonald furrow Tecton of
neutrino sheila phoner zombies are at
night river for massa the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences has decided to award
the 2015
Prize in Physics to Takaaki kajita and
Arthur B McDonald for the discovery of
neutrino oscillations which shows that
neutrinos have mass few DM taken for
neutrino oscillation on the dovish
medicine birthdays neutrinos Mesaba
public over desolation a neutrino key
mode culinary no only mass the creature
as the Latin a 3-node store pegasi wire
straw when eighteen of yes Massah
thank you and now the chair of the Nobel
Committee professor Lily will give us a
brief introduction and please at this
moment in this room they are more than a
billion neutrinos which father almost at
the speed of light these elementary
particles are the second most abundant
in the universe next to the photons
which are the particles of light they
are created in nuclear reactions for
example in in the Sun in stars or in
nuclear power points they interact very
little with the environment for example
they can go through earth without being
stopped there are three kinds of
neutrinos electron neutrinos Leo
neutrinos and tau neutrinos this year's
prize is awarded to the experiment
discovery that neutrinos can change
identity for example an immunity RINO
can become a tau neutrino and vice versa
they oscillate the observations were
made by two research groups one at the
super-kamiokande detector in Japan and
the other at Sudbury neutrino
Observatory in Canada the discovery
implies that neutrinos which were
believed to be
massless do have a mass even if very
little and since there are so many of
them it changes our view of the universe
thank you on now professor olga button
will give us some insights into the
science behind the prize neutrinos are
puzzle and this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics honors a fundamental step
towards unveiling the nature of the
neutrino as we just heard neutrinos are
very common fundamental particles many
are created in the solar core others are
created when cosmic rays collide with
atoms in the atmosphere others still are
created by decays of radioactive
elements in the earth crust or in our
nuclear reactors every second billions
of neutrinos passed through our bodies
unfelt and unseen neutrinos are nature's
most elusive particles they hardly ever
interact but sometimes a neutrino will
strike an atom and when it does charged
particles are produced and those we can
detect and this is how we know that
there are three kinds of neutrinos we
call them flavours neutrino flavors we
have electron neutrinos those when they
interact always produce the electrons
but we also have muon neutrinos and tau
neutrinos which upon interaction produce
muons and Tau's immunes and towns are
heavier relatives of the electrons they
have properties just like the electrons
they just have here and apart from that
this is about all we know about
neutrinos and for more than half a
century we used to think that neutrinos
are massless
a discovery the discovery of neutrino
oscillations at the turn of the middling
millennium upset our notions this
discovery comes in two parts the first
part has to do with the neutrinos from
the atmosphere the atmospheric neutrinos
and the second part with solar neutrinos
and I'll start with the atmospheric
neutrinos particle showers in the
atmosphere produce neutrinos they
produce electron neutrinos and muon
neutrinos kahit isang headed a group of
researchers using the super-kamiokande
detector deep underground in a sink mine
about 250 kilometers northwest of Tokyo
in a study of the atmospheric neutrino
flux they wanted to know how the
atmospheric neutrino flux varied as a
function of energy and arrival direction
now neutrinos arrived at
super-kamiokande from all directions
they arrived from above but they also
arrived from below they traversed the
entire earth without interacting we have
heard that neutrinos were very very
elusive they hardly ever interact so
it's not so surprising that they can
traverse the whole earth and reach the
super-kamiokande from below where's the
electron neutrino count in
super-kamiokande seemed ok the
researchers discovered that muon
neutrinos seemed to disappear by
traveling to the detector and the more
so the farther they traveled now here's
a photograph showing the
super-kamiokande detector a huge tank
filled with 50,000 tons of ultra-pure
water and i've circled i try to see
I've circled a group of three
technicians just to show you the
proportions of this tank so there's a
huge tank filled with 50 thousand tons
of water and the volume of this tank is
monitored by about 11,000 optical
sensors and these sensors can detect not
the neutrinos themselves which are
invisible but when they rarely interact
with an atom producing charged particles
electrons and lures and when these
charged particles move through the water
they produce light images rings like the
ring I've shown you here and so electron
and new and neutrinos can be
distinguished by means of these rings
tau neutrinos are generally not detected
by supporting candy
meanwhile on the other side of of the
earth Indian Ontario province in Canada
there was a detector which was capable
of counting all the neutrino flavours
the Sudbury neutrino Observatory
detector was used by a group of
scientists headed by Arthur B McDonald
in a study of solar neutrinos the
photograph shows the super committee the
Sudbury neutrino Observatory detector a
sphere 12 metres in diameter filled with
ultra pure heavy water 1,000 tonnes of
it now heavy water is just like regular
water except that in each h2o molecule
the hydrogen atom is exchanged for
heavier isotope of hydrogen - cheerio so
as hydrogen in its nucleus contains just
one proton deuterium contains a proton
and a neutron and this makes all the
difference when neutrinos collide with
you terian two reactions are possible
either on the left hand that your chair
iam new clothes is associated or on the
right hand the neutrino is absorbed by
the neutron and an electron is produced
so these two reactions can be
distinguished and whereas the left hand
reaction counts only chinos independent
of flavor the right reaction counts only
electron neutrinos the Sun produces only
electron neutrinos so knowing that we
expect that the camp of both the left
and the right hand side reaction should
be equal however as I know observed that
was the total neutrino count was as
expected the electron neutrinos seem to
disappear so we have two observations
and it turns out that these two
observations together pick out one
single explanation the neutrinos change
flavor while traveling through space and
this means that if we try to determine
neutrino flavor as a function of
distance or as a function of time will
find that this flavor changes and we are
talking in terms of neutrino flavor
oscillations neutrino flavor
oscillations is an effect which all the
surprising is explained by quantum
theory in quantum theory particles
moving through space are described by
waves these waves overlap they interfere
and this is what we interpret as much in
oscillations quantum theory also tells
us that this neutrino metamorphosis is
only possible if neutrinos are not
massless as opposed to what we used to
believe neutrinos must have nonzero mass
the discovery that neutrinos has have
mass has profound consequences not only
for particle physics pointing at physics
be
on the Sun that model but those of
astrophysics and for cosmology the
discoverer of neutrino oscillations has
opened a new exciting and challenging
field of physics and all of the world
scientists are picking up this challenge
to unveil the true nature of the
neutrino thank you thank you very much
Olga we may now have professor McDonald
with us on the phone and remember it's
around 4 o'clock or so in the morning in
Canada so we have professor Michael on
phone hello hello professor McDonald a
good morning again I'm the guy who woke
you up 45 minutes ago right now I'm
sitting in the beautiful session hall of
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
here in Stockholm and we are in the
midst of the press conference with the
many interested journalists from Sweden
and abroad and I'm sure they are eager
to ask you questions are you ready I
think so who would like to start too
much fun ain't it thank you
good morning professor this is Swedish
television for Nina speaking
congratulations
thank you so much on behalf of myself
and also my many collaborators on our
experiment neutrinos are very elusive so
you've been chasing something extremely
elusive was there at any time a moment
when you thought okay we are really on
to something here
yes there certainly was a Eureka moment
in this experiment when we were able to
see that Latinos appeared to change from
one type to the other in traveling the
Sun
for the earth fortunately with the
availability of heavy water it was
became clear and our physical accuracy
in greater and we were able to be
certain that this was a proven with
great accuracy oh yes there was that
Eureka moment
thank you thank you more questions yes
please see the back oh no for a second
you get the microphone okay I wonder you
just get better the neutrino has mass
and is the biggest imp what is the
biggest impact that this discovery has
what will its change so neutrinos are
among the fundamental particles you do
not know how to subdivide any further
and therefore their fundamental level is
very important when you do not know and
whether they have its otherwise and how
to operate them into those theories that
give us a more complete understanding
the world of physics at a most
fundamental level discovering this
property therefore helps us tremendously
in that regard
they also have significant inspiration
in of the universe as evolved and
knowing whether or not they are massive
whether they change there might also
help to unravel those mysteries as well
but do you know any do you know anything
that will change what's used do you know
any practical use well I guess one could
type the fact that in addition to
observing neutrinos as having changed
their type we in particular were
observing neutrinos from the core of the
Sun and in the process of making our
measurements we were able to verify the
understanding of how the processes in
the core of the Sun things that have
been calculated in detail by people like
John but all that they were very
accurate those processes are similar to
the processes that these days people are
attempting to produce here on earth in
the process of developing fusion power
so it's held in place by gravity rather
than magnetic fields but knowing that we
have a very strong indication that we
understand what's happening at a large
degree of accuracy in the Sun helps us
in terms of standing the physic the same
a fusion process in fusion power thank
you next question please
David Keaton from The Associated Press
professor congratulations the question
I'd like to ask you is you've spent
decades working in laboratories behind
closed doors with very few people
outside experts that are aware of your
research how did it feel this morning at
four o'clock in the morning when Sweden
when you receive this phone call from
Sweden telling you that you had won this
prize and that's the eyes of the world
would be upon you today it's a very
daunting I have any colleagues as well
who care the eyes with me in tremendous
amount of work they have accomplished
this measurement
so we have a very friendly collaboration
among scientists from Anna to the United
States Portugal and that group gives me
someone who's me a group of people with
the mic then enjoy the moment
least when I get a chance to talk with
them so there's great camaraderie
associated with this work even though
he's many years working to try to a
puppet thank you do we have more
questions yes we're going to doggies new
hello i'm maria gunther from doggins
nieto
congratulations to the prize I would
like to know what more questions about
the near tree near was still would like
to get down to two well there are a
number of experiments that are ongoing
as measurement in which one looks for a
rare radioactivity all three
knowledgeable indicate that enabled one
is the bird be able to take such a
measurement well as other direct the
fortunate thing the underground
laboratory really create the lowest
radioactivity created we believe is also
a location where by eliminating other
forms of interfering radioactivity we
are able to make very significant
measurement of quantities like you know
the beta decay other whether there are
other a whole program of the quino
measurement internationally in order to
determine their properties
thank you very much or the more
questions for yes general
my name is Jonah rose from Washington
Flamsteed congratulations to the prize I
wonder did you have any collaboration
with your colleague the other Lauren
about Bryce Pataki kinda actually as it
happens we were together in Reno Italy
weeks ago at a conference person whom I
have the greatest we were able to
combine them with but I've been made for
candy late and we later were able to go
on with our own yes we have any
communication over the years and have a
very positive relationship you are the
more questions
yes over there hello away from China
national television I want to ask you
some personal questions what does this
Warner mean to you and how will you
spend your reward money what will it
mean to me it means that the work that
our collaboration has undertaken and
accomplished starting back in 1984 with
our founding spokesman herb Chen passed
away a few years ago from the University
of California at Irvine and Dirk Doohan
who is a very good friend of mine and a
parent University they
only 16 of us parted as now I'm to the
point where it has been internationally
recognized we of course are very
satisfied that we have been able to add
to the world's knowledge of physics at a
very fundamental level of course this
recognition is something that is a
tremendous accolade for our group thank
you thank you okay
thank you are there more questions for
professor McDonald if not thank you very
much um professor McDonald and
congratulations again and welcome to
Stockholm in December you won our hearts
thank you very much bye-bye all right
okay let's move on to any questions to
our experts on the panel questions this
is your chance everything crystal clear
but if there is something you wonder
about some question that hasn't been
answered yet you have your chance now
yes I wonder if you got in contact with
also with Peggy Carter before the
conference yes we did we spoke to him
just after we spoke to Professor
McDonough
we couldn't rig up the phone line but we
have spoken to him and he was he was
very happy delighted to receive the
Nobel Prize and he's coming in December
are the questions
well then if yes please thank you very
much Lucia from people stealing I want
to ask you
neutrinos has must have mass so I want
to know how do you measure the mass and
how much is it Thank You Olga so what we
know from the study of neutrino
oscillations is that neutrinos have mass
or at least one of the three neutrino
flavours does have mass it's very hard
to measure the mass itself and it's one
of these outstanding challenges that
professor McDonald has just been
describing we have been trying to
measure neutrino mass for more than 70
years but the only thing we know is an
upper limit on the masses and the best
upper limit comes from cosmology it's of
the order of 0.2 electron volts which is
more than a million times lighter than
the electron so that's the only thing I
can tell you then you Chino has a mass
and it's more than a million times
lighter than the election but exactly
how much the mass is is an outstanding
challenge of the field thank you what's
that the last question if so thank you
for attending and those who you have
requested it abuse within Nobel
Committee members they will commence
immediately after we close their session
but let's close now and welcome back for
the announcement of the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry tomorrow at 11:45 a.m. thank
you very much
the object restoring a Phoenix
[Music]
ngah Bucknell you are a member of Nobel
Committee for physics and this year's
prize is about neutrinos what is the
prize for exactly so this year the prize
honors a fundamental discovery in
physics and since neutrinos are very
common in our surroundings and they have
very common particles in the universe
the discovery that neutrinos actually
not massless makes a difference it makes
a difference theoretically but it also
makes the difference to how our Sun
functions if it wouldn't be for
neutrinos the Sun would not be shining
any more if it wouldn't be for neutrinos
supernovas would not be exploding the
way they explode the elements that we
are all made of would not exist so
neutrinos are very important but this is
fundamental physics
what are neutrinos among these few
fundamental particles which make up
matter and we know them from radioactive
decays but what they really are and no
one knows no one has ever seen a
neutrino neutrinos have no electric
charge and we can only detect particles
which carry electric charge and so we
can only discover neutrinos when they
interact with something and produce
charged particles and this is how we
know that three kinds of neutrinos but
no one has ever seen the neutrino itself
and the price is actually for discovery
of neutrinos oscillations that neutrinos
change identities also
what does it mean well it means that new
chinos it's very hard to say that the
new Treena changes identity because it
makes you think of the fact that you
know you have a neutrino sitting on the
table in front of you and over all of a
sudden they become something else
so neutrinos do not change identity like
that they change identity while they
move through space when they do that you
can produce one kind of neutrino but
then if you try to detect it 100
hundreds of kilometers further away you
discover that what you catch it's not
the same kind of neutrino but a
different kind Contino so something has
happened on the way from the source to
the detector and this is what we call
neutrino oscillations and this has to do
with quantum mechanics and quantum
mechanics I can see that you know as
soon as you say quantum mechanics people
get totally you know this is not for me
I don't want you know I'm not going to
understand it but in reality it's not
that difficult quantum mechanics
describes particles moving through space
like waves so if you think of waves in a
pond like someone throwing two stones in
a pond both stones will create waves and
these waves will interfere and likewise
in space neutrinos moving in space I
describe my waves these ways interfere
they overlap and this is what we
discover in the form of solutions so we
said it's an interpretation of a quantum
mechanical phenomenon and the two
laurits this year they made big
experiments
big collaborations how come these two
scientists were awarded this prize so it
is true these two scientists the heart
of the collaborations we have the
Sudbury neutrino Observatory
collaboration headed by art McDonald
since 1990 art was one of the 16 people
who proposed Sudbury neutrino
Observatory back in 1994 so he has
really been in the journey from the very
beginning he has made a proposal he has
built the observatory he has been the
organizational and intellectual leader
of this venture on the other side we
have this super-kamiokande Observatory
in a mine in Japan super-kamiokande
works somewhat differently
super-kamiokande is a second generation
of servitor II following they come you
convey Takaaki kajita
worked on kamiokande while a PhD student
and he worked with atmospheric neutrinos
we're moving to super-kamiokande he led
one of the three experimental groups
trying to make sense of the data they
were getting so he was leading the
atmospheric neutrino group and trying to
investigate the properties of the
neutrinos so he was the intellectual
leader of this effort and both made
discoveries around the turn of this
millennium
you mentioned that neutrinos still are a
big puzzle so what's going on since then
so since then we've discovered that
neutrinos are even more of a challenge
than we thought they were because okay
if neutrinos are massless we do not
understand it but at least the mass
identical to zero is one of the
fundamental constants of the universe
and just describes the universe we live
in now we know that Muccino mass is not
zero so now the question becomes why is
it not zero and why is it so small so if
we if we physicists discover something
which is very small but actually not
equal to zero we get very excited
because there must be something which
makes this quantity is small but not
zero so there is a lot of experimental
activity one trying to determine exactly
what the mass is we don't know what the
mass is
we only know an upper limit we want to
know why the mass is so small and of
course theorists have lots of proposals
we want to know why neutrinos only
appear in a left-handed variety and not
in the right-handed variety they may be
a new type of particle just for the Maya
run a particle so people are trying to
figure out that and so you know in the
end this discovery of neutrino
oscillations has created a wide open
field so instead of just trying to
determine what the neutrino mass is
we're not trying to determine the
properties of the Moschino and this made
teachers a whole lot of new things about
the universe
you yourself or a spokesperson for the
big experiment on this South Pole can
you tell us about neutrinos yes I always
love to tell about neutrinos at the
South Pole yeah I'm the spokesperson of
the international ice cream
collaboration so we are about 300
scientists working with a detective
buried deep underground will be low the
surface of Antarctica at the South Pole
there is a detector in the glacier
detecting not atmospheric and not so
long as she knows but we hope to see
neutrinos coming from the outer space we
do the check atmospheric neutrinos but
to us this is not a signal it's a
calibration source so since we so since
that theory is describing how the
atmosphere functions we use the
atmospheric neutrinos to calibrate our
detector however a few years ago in 2013
we discovered the flux from the outer
space neutrinos coming not from our
galaxy but somewhere from the outside of
our galaxy and this is the first for
this discovery I skip was named the
breakthrough of the year 2013 and now we
are continuing on this path and try to
learn more about these cosmic neutrinos
which sources produced them and how they
get these enormous energies which are
millions of times larger than what the
Sun is capable of doing and what we can
do with our man-made terrestrial
accelerators so once more there is a lot
of experiments about neutrinos they are
going on why is it so important to know
just
neutrinos what they are well this is an
important question and this year's prize
is for fundamental physics definitely
now the use of fundamental physics for
society is something which I could
discuss at length but it's clear that
humans have this urge to learn more
about the universe that we live in and
fundamental science is one of the
pillars of modern society so I usually
say that if we didn't have this urge we
would still be living in caves and we
would still be afraid of the lightning
but having learned what we have we have
built a modern society with computers
with GPS with cures for cancer all these
things are phase of discoveries in
fundamental science Einstein didn't
develop the special relativity to give
us GPS but we have GPS and it's based a
lot of this special what are these
general theory of relativity we are
still curious yes thank you very much
Mary
you